well somebody was gonna snatch him up
but this is an interesting twist so I
have not talked about James Gunn in a
little bit not since his frankly screwed
up firing from Disney and getting kicked
off
guardians of the galaxy 3 I don't want
to rehash all of that but just for
context and as a reminder James Gunn was
in the middle of working on guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 when some people
politically opposed to him because James
Gunn is very outspoken in his political
beliefs basically trolled through a
bunch of his old tweets dug up some
stuff that was let's go with blue not
particularly in good taste humor from
well before his hiring at Disney and
then created a big stink about it and
Disney as most companies most big
corporations are want to do cut him
loose rather than risk having him
tarnish the brand even though it became
fairly clear in the weeks that follow
that there was massive support for
rehire and Goong including within the
cast of guardians of the galaxy Dave
Bautista has been the most outspoken
about that pretty much anybody paying
close attention to how this all went
down if they said anything at all they
tended to side with Gunn Disney did not
rehire him and well now he's found other
work and that other work is with Warner
Brothers working on a DC property so the
story broke that James Gunn has been
hired to write the script for with an
option to direct Suicide Squad - now
this huh if this pans out if this
happens and if it's good and if it makes
strong returns Disney's gonna have egg
on its face even more than it already
does because the
is is that ultimately the initial
decision to fire gun was a knee-jerk
protect the brand reaction they didn't
look into the stuff that was dug up as
well as they should have to understand
where it was coming from how old it was
the context under which it was said and
the context under which it was dug up
they didn't do that they just smelled
scandal cut him loose and moved forward
which is you again that's your standard
corporate procedure in something like
that now the reason that they didn't
reverse the decision despite basically
everybody arguing that they should have
that came down more much more to
protecting the executives who made the
decision rather than protecting the
brand because it's your standard just
corporate executive level playbook
that if you realize you made a mistake
you don't and definitely not in the
immediate aftermath you don't reverse it
you don't double back on it you don't
second-guess yourself because it makes
you look weak as a leader what you do is
you power through it and you hope that
your future successes are enough to get
people's mind off that mistake that you
made it may be down the road you can go
yeah that could have been half but in
the immediate aftermath you do not
acknowledge that you made a mistake you
power forward because otherwise it just
brings every decision you make into
question well you know as a leader he
said this but is that gonna be reversed
he reversed this other thing so that the
fact that he that gun was not rehired
had much more to do with protecting
corporate rear-ends
you know executives specifically rather
than protecting the brand of Marvel and
Disney as a whole and yeah I'm not gonna
go so far as to say executives are gonna
get fired over this but they're
definitely some exact would not be
shocked if a few executives are quietly
reshuffled or if they just have a lot
more scrutiny on their future projects
for this because now not only have
they lost basically the guy who
constructed the entire Marvel cosmic end
of the MCU and was doing it phenomenally
well but he's now gone to the direct
competition in the same genre so yeah
this is this this looks bad but let's
set that that context and all that
nonsense aside let's just talk base
level James Gunn working on Suicide
Squad that has the potential to be
really quite good because James Gunn
look I don't think I don't think James
Gunn has made a bad movie that he's
directed I think some of the scripts
he's written haven't always turned into
good movies but basically things that he
saw through to the end I would say
though the theist one was probably super
but even super was pretty good and had
some really fascinating ideas even if it
didn't all come together in the end so
the guy's got a really strong track
record but now again I'll point it out
he's not yet hired to direct he's
currently only hired to script and I'm
betting that that is an allowance that
they made for him I have no doubt that
Warner Brothers wants him to direct but
you know James Gunn he's a pretty savvy
guy you'll notice that of all the people
talking about how he should be rehired
and everything he himself kept pretty
quiet and he's been pretty candid he's
been pretty just clever and you know
doing the smartest move available to him
under the circumstances throughout this
whole process I think he's pretty
intelligent I think he's been paying
attention and if you asked him paying
attention then he knows that what
happened to the first Suicide Squad
was David a or who who worked on the
script and directed that was given an
incredibly short amount of time to work
on the script and it had massive
interference in the direction so
whatever reassurances Warner Brothers
might have given James Gunn my suspicion
is that he said look I'll write the
script and once I have a feel for how
that process went and if I can get the
sense that you guys aren't gonna be you
know breathing down my neck every step
of the way and hire a trailer company to
recut the movie
I'm done then maybe I'll direct it it's
my suspicion that he's gonna see what
the process of writing for Warner
Brothers and mortor brothers DC stuff is
like before he makes the commitment to
actually direct it now there's a decent
chance it'll go well for him because the
DC EU is not under the same management
in terms of the specific executives in
charge of it now that it was at the time
Suicide Squad happened so again stepping
away trying to step away from the
corporate stuff completely looking at
the creative possibilities James Gunn
works with ensembles really well I mean
that's what guardians of the galaxy
flies on it's terrific team dynamics and
Suicide Squad has the potential to do
that the movie didn't deliver and had a
handful of decent performances and a
couple of interesting scenes but on the
whole just didn't just didn't pull
together at all it was a jumbled mess
but especially if he gets to work with
Margot Robbie if he gets Will Smith back
you know I in you know you can throw
other people in there you're not stuck
with the other characters you don't need
to have flag again you don't need to
have Killer Croc or katana gay you could
have them again and maybe even you know
James gonna figure out something to do
with them that is better but I think
you're the only two who you need whopped
three the three that you need to have
are gonna be Margot Robbie Will Smith
and Viola Davis as Amanda Waller that's
it everybody else is up for grabs and
that's kind of the nature of the Suicide
Squad
you can move characters in or out
because you know it's a suicide mission
people aren't expected to survive or
maybe the skillset of somebody like
Captain Boomerang doesn't make any sense
for the mission that this new group is
getting sent on so they pull somebody
else instead do though to be honest
captain boomerangs skillset didn't
really make sense last time either let's
not dwell on that but like James Gunn is
really good at balancing group dynamics
I mean that's that's what we've been
watching him do with guardians of the
galaxy so as far as properties goes this
is a really good fit for him and
especially if Warner Brothers leaves him
alone just lets him do his thing which
they might do it does seem
they're they're realizing that the level
of corporate oversight and interference
that they have been engaging in wasn't
helping it's distinctly possible in most
of the cases where it's pretty clear
that there was a lot of you know big
stepping in from the higher-ups that
maybe the product that they had wasn't
that good in the first place that's
distinctly possible I'd say with at
least a handful of these but them
stepping in and doing all this extra
stuff definitely didn't help and they
seem to seem - at least for the time
being haven't realized that much now the
only reason I feel a little bit bummed
out about this you know because I'm not
bummed out about this because it hurts
Disney I don't really keep like as much
as Disney makes a ton of products that I
like I have no particular love of Disney
as a corporation so you know I but I'm
not like yeah suck it to Disney but
neither am i like oh man that's a bummer
for them I don't really care the owners
I'm kind of bummed out is a podcasting
friend of mine a guy by the name of
Diablo Frank he had said that if James
Gunn is gonna get hired by another
studio that he hoped he'd get hired by
Universal to take over and retool their
dark universe the thing that the mummy
was supposed to kick off and I kind of
want to see that more than him doing the
Suicide Squad but since I'm not gonna
get that and from the look of it I want
to see what he does with the Suicide
Squad I want to see what kind of
dynamics he pulls and I want to see what
characters he sticks it I want to see
what kind of scenario he throws them
into because he again he gets these
kinds of characters and he gets that
whatever kind of situation you put them
in has to pull out interesting things
from the characters and from their
interactions it's not enough just to
throw everything at the wall and throw
all these characters at a threat and you
get a movie out of it cuz the first
Suicide Squad was barely a movie it was
fun in parts and I know some people like
I have a co-worker who like unabashedly
loves it and he can't really seem to
explain to me why but I don't know maybe
maybe part of my problem is I've seen
now two animated Suicide Squad films but
yeah
James Gunn directed a Suicide Squad Wow
writing possibly directing a Suicide
Squad movie I want to see that what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's also a whole
bunch of buttons and links you can push
click on them they take you places
including to my patreon if you feel like
it but if you don't don't worry about it
because remember folks you are the
council and I just run the meetings
until next time this council is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]